hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to spine a game by suits and
nukes who made all those other weird and
wacky and far-out their games that we
played in the past they seem to be able
to crank out games very quickly but this
is supposed to be a different experiment
more ethereal or etheral as I love to
pronounce it or not ethereal that's the
wrong word anyway what everyone I came
out tonight
it's getting late no it better make a
stop at the restroom real quick before
hitting the road okay also may I note
that the specific art style that this
game developer has it's just a little
off-putting in general oh that's
actually nice oh this is lovely
why am I supposed to go hello thank you
for the pancakes
why are you wrapped up in a blanket are
you okay hellooo alrighty then carrying
on staff only ha oh God
why is everyone in these cams so creepy
even the Penguins were creepy and the
penguin was a murderer oh there we go
hello ah this is mildly disconcerting
okay my mime reflection moves it
slightly the wrong pace as I do and also
there's a note on the wall do I need
that already then don't mind me okay
okey-dokey then I keep expecting
something to happen it just seems like
something's gonna happen oh don't worry
about washing your hands no hygiene here
can I click on that then Oh some kind of
new wonder who left it I'm not yet sure
what has happened every time I try to
leave this diner I end up right back
inside I'm leaving this note as proof to
myself proof that I can't possibly be
returning to the same space it's hard to
imagine even writing this I know how
moving around works one foot in front of
the other same as it's always been
so why the hell am I not going anywhere
well I don't know you tell me is that me
writing that note is that my reflection
writing that note something's going on
here something's a little funky oh okay
Oh alrighty then I guess I won't go that
way help you I can't click on you
anybody here hello oh I don't know wait
whoa the person in the blankets is gone
but the blanket is still there why are
they there okay are you also trapped
here Oh what
am I going crazy or something I get it
Wow hello is anybody whoa that's weird
hi okay enter the kitchen all right why
am I in here do I need anything from
here do I need some tools for some
reason okay the blankets yay
alrighty then a little disturbing still
don't know what's going on okay I go I
that's weird
oh geez I'm looking to the painting on
the wall back there seems to be an odd
odd piece of art choice hi
who's the Oh God oh jeez okay okay I'm
gonna pretend like that piss demon
didn't just come out of the piss
dimension and then haunt my dreams don't
mind me just gonna you know give a thing
in here alone forever apparently
alrighty then sort of personal travel
and you hello and welcome to the
exciting world of interdimensional
travel it can be pretty exciting to
wander the mysterious landscapes of the
multiverse but it can also be dangerous
remember to always follow the
interdimensional rules and regulations
when passing between possibilities gates
to begin the instruction inserts taste
now
I don't have tape - do you have tape - I
don't know where tape to would be I'm
just gonna carry on being lost and
looping back and forth forever I assume
who's gonna check aha hello another no I
wonder what it says oh I'm gonna read it
after what I just saw I'm not even sure
what's real anymore are you still there
yellow child am I still I don't know
what here is I don't know what there is
I don't know where we are I don't know
where anything is
alrighty then
okay alrighty then I'll hide in here
Kate
fundamentals of moving through the
multiverse imagine an ant crawling
across the sheet of paper okay think of
the paper as representing a plane of
existence and the ant is our technology
has finally progressed to the point
where it is now possible to connect
different planes of existence the same
way we can connect two or more sheets of
paper just as the ant moves from page to
page you too can travel from existence
to existence inserts tape for more
information I I'm not I'm not fully
following you there was a weird meat
monster that assembled out of
nothingness outside this hallway and I'm
assuming that these lines are marking
how many times I've been here but
apparently I don't remember it until
just now so I guess I'm just gonna get
out of here
is it gonna kill me is it still there Oh
gonna hold ya cover your face that's a
good idea okay just gonna oh there it is
okay
well hi weird interdimensional green
sweating did you drink your Gatorade all
right I'm out of here huh okay then oh
good
the artwork is even better than before
I'm so glad
I mean Monster welcome back to this
plane of existence oh god there's no
more tutorial machine oh boy yeah
nothing here okay I guess I got to go
out to the meat monster which is okay
just turned around so if I go quickly
now quickly now quickly now quickly
quickly quickly quickly quickly quickly
herp whoa here you you didn't see me did
you you didn't see nothing oh okay hey
okay then lady can I get another note
please or do I have to die oh there we
go
ah here I go leaving mark scribbling
notes how long have I been doing this
again how long am i capable of doing
this just delirious need to get a grip
need to keep going can't stop can't stop
so is this
is that another meat monster is that
coming in here okay alrighty then
so that's good don't know okay so I got
a I got a only exit when it's just about
not there you yell really okay where's
the other one okay no is that the only
one I don't think that's the only one is
it okay it's the only one okay you're
not gonna kill me this time
oh hey Grim Reaper are you doing good to
see you again alright it's gonna go in
here hope for another tape on
interdimensional travel that's gonna
tell me all the things I got em it's an
interesting concept and it's a bit but
panicking to know I'm probably gonna die
hi again welcome to this plane of
existence okay he's gonna go that way oh
[ __ ]
okay Herpa derpa dirt oh I just noticed
the guy in that painting looking at me
so deliriously he uh he's really
interested in what he sees oh there's
another note over there I gotta get that
before I get out of here okay hi hello
ah that's no bueno why do you have a
booth gross just gonna meander this way
hey whoo okay I've had a run in with the
yellow child once more this time I
grabbed him an easier task than I would
have imagined previously it was upon the
seizure that the facade fell away and I
learned of his true nature Simon as he
likes to go by is not of this world that
is as I learned before he once again
disappeared
he is of this world only of another
dimension in a strange way the likes of
which I cannot fully explain I feel as
if I already knew that I must press on I
must be on the right track well I didn't
see anybody who are you talking about
why is he just standing there
ya know what it is with its weird
cross-sectional butthole mouth I don't
know you don't smell nothing you don't
smell nothing you don't smell nothing
that's right
turn around what are you doing okay how
about keep whoa you thought you were
gonna get something anything you did mmm
alrighty then oh it's just a kitty cat
it wants to be patted its purring so
nicely alrighty then nothing else in
here oh hello I've recovered a device
that details the monster these flying
meatballs as I've been referring to him
at this point are known as quantum
keepers a rose by any other name it
should seem regardless of what you want
to call them they spell death any way
you slice it I will continue to avoid
these quantum keepers at least until
when or perhaps if a better way reveals
itself if they do come to dissolve to
their Dark Matter state if the PLD unit
I recovered is to be believed upon
absorbing a paradox
then I perhaps I can come to use this
tomato I didn't understand a word of any
of that I have no idea what you're
talking about is there anything in here
to help me how long am I gonna be
looping through the oh hey hi again
which way you're going which way you
gotta go sassy [ __ ] oh come on don't do
nothing to me yeah you're getting goop
on my pants me buddy boobie a bit a bit
a bit of a doom okay oh thank you the
familiar faces of friends always good
as I count the hash marks on the wall 46
in total I find I'm jumping randomly
assuming I'm following a line along the
likes of me whose left notes as well as
occasionally being interlaced with the
me who is chosen to not leave notes
given the progress I can only conclude
the path if there indeed is a path is
random at best I've found little to no
coherency no numerical or structural
rhyme and reason I find only that every
time I cross through the exit door the
only true option left to me I return to
the same diner I'll be it ever so
slightly altered sometimes altered in
ways I cannot imagine but except in the
rarest of occasions different from any
I've been do before I fear I'm losing my
mind okay this is really interesting
because it's like a layering of layering
of like different realities that you
could go through and also there's no
there's no uh orbital doodad or over
there this time so what does that mean
is there anything in here is um am I
just gonna be looping forever is there
anything here Oh goddammit okay I just
got a run from this one okay holy [ __ ]
oh well as if returned example a fun
enough web abba-abba-abba keeps popping
in and out of existence size of a six or
seven-year-old taunts me finally
something seems to be able to see and
answer me I get a petulant little Brad
made of lighter start us or something
okay then that didn't help me at all
okay gotta go gotta go we and I'm not
died of that thing sooner or later
I don't think there's a save mechanic so
I don't know how it's gonna handle it
first off if it was nothing like I'd
ever experienced in my life one moment I
felt my bits and bobs scattered about
drunk as a skunk and then like it never
happened sober as a judge I vaguely
recall rating the alcohol storage why
not right
flying meatballs of death circling
around the place never-ending
unexplainable diner atmosphere yellow
children made of drugs hallucinations
then like it never had happened I push
through the door and there I am
completely reset
here this Bazaar got this gotta be
something here it's gotta be something
waiting for me to discover it right
maybe not maybe not at all gotcha
whoa okay what the [ __ ] happened I don't
think so you are the cause of all this
aren't you
you're gonna tell me what's going on
right now leave me alone
let me go tough guy huh we'll see about
that
we'll see about what what am i doing am
I gonna give him a swirly oh I'm gonna
give him a swirly aren't I well I'm
gonna give him a swirly tell me
everything or you're really gonna get I
need to find the one who exits no let me
go I warned you you made me do this
[Music]
what am I just gonna drown him oh no
whoa the one who heads it of course of
course I've been so blind it wasn't a
question of where but of when it's so
obvious now what are you talking about
what's going on where am I
hmm go through the back door just one
more time I'll explain everything to you
then but hurry the keepers are coming
what the [ __ ] happened when did I get
old he likes some shine some light into
my mouth and I'm crippled II an old
enforcement of interdimensional safety
laws and regulations okay
order maintained balance between planes
of existence [ __ ] enforces commonly
referred to as quantum keepers are
dispatched to nullify any paradoxes that
may arise the sole purpose of these
creatures is to track down any
paradoxical entity that can present
itself within a looping time scale once
any threat to be eliminated they simply
fade from existence and convert to dark
matter state until the heat called on at
the end repeating the cycle as necessary
no frightening can experience the
quantum keeper plays a crucial role in
protecting against paradoxes that may
otherwise spread to surrounding planes
of existence and restore order to the
multiverse okay the fifth dimensional
travel 101 as a user of 5d technology
your capabilities for passage stemmed
beyond ours with mention of status to
lower levels of existence think back to
the idea of an ant traveling along a
sheet of paper imagine now if the paper
were to be rolled up so that both ends
are now touching as the end moves from
one end of the sheet for the next a loop
is created inhabitants in this existence
are bound to the sheet as their boards
are governed by the walls in this
dimension as a fifth dimension of
traveling however you are free to cross
to any point on any plane at any given
open such freedoms must be tempered with
caution as failure to act within the
safety guidelines could disrupt not only
the currently occupied possibilities
based but rupture adjacent planes of
existence as well causing great risks to
echo across the infinities fear travel
with caution
good God why would anybody be given the
responsibility to do that just be able
to cross across dimensions and then
interact with all the other universes in
this universe my god that's that's
branching into concepts of spine again I
don't know what spine means Gately
avoiding paradox
okay our accents at interdimensional
travelers and echo unforeseen
cick went across the farthest reaches of
infinity therefore we must tread
carefully to avoid setting into motion
any event that can alter the course of
other planes of existence
remember the care and maintenance of all
the worlds and their inhabitants is
everyone's responsibility refer to the
handbook the do's and do not do of
interdimensional travel I get it with
your device for more information
oh I get it I'm not the interdimensional
traveler that thing was I thought it was
about me the whole time no I'm the ant
in the equation we're the ant we're not
being a dimensional traveler we're the
ant that's being bounced into over and
over again and that was rolled up into a
loop like that analogy wasn't just a
metaphor it's literal example what's
happening here and I don't know what
spine means but I'm assuming it's not
good the game is now ready for part two
click this message to open part 2 after
clicking give it a second you may need
to allow access the same way you did in
part 1 alternatively if this process
fails a crassus you can download each
part separately from the game page oh no
ok we are renowned oh that's not good
well will will will will will I'm
guessing you've got me spotted and I
gotta get going so what would happen if
I wait oh that paradox is now dandy I'm
gonna just you know close the other one
well [ __ ] Miller
okay I'm gonna you know I'm gonna go
into the kitchen baby can I hide oh my
god I can't hide him too old right now
for real
all right I'm going for it freedom and
also I do realize that's the old guy
that was in the blanket I in the
beginning of the game I do remember that
I do 100% remember that and I can't go
in there anymore
hey you don't look so good why don't you
take it easy Jillian Katie come over
here for just a second huh Oh what is it
Tom
do we still have that blanket and loss
of found the red one um I think so yeah
could you go grab that and bring it over
to our friend here looks like he could
use it oh sure thing
why do you have a seat here at the booth
I'll be right back I'm dead now can you
hear me okay sir
oh geez you had a fall back there why
don't you rest up if you need anything
just let us know
take all the time you need uh-huh hi
that's right I'm surprised he recognized
me without my head inside a toilet
lately I'm sorry I was just so scared
and I know I'm the one who should be
sorry
none of this was your fault you're
simply caught up in something I was
doing and for that well I guess we both
kind of screwed up I don't understand
maybe this will clear things up remember
this don't worry
only you can see me that's is that me in
a way I'm not like you you know where I
come from from all possibilities exist
those all eyes and not at all
I don't know Beck's I do understand your
kind simply
but I've come to realize I made a big
mistake and I must spend the rest of
what you call forever fixing that
mistake you're you're going to be doing
this forever
no silly just for what will you call
forever forever is not as long as you
think it is but that's not for you to
understand not now anyway
well I ever understand all that's
happened here
perhaps in time but right this second
wouldn't you rather leave this place hi
yes then go out the front door this time
go before you end up leaving out the
back again go you are the one who leaves
ok
oopsy poopsy doop Co which way am I
going now hope it the bombardier up I'm
such I'm such a goof I'm such a gosh
darn goof well never mind I can't go
that way
alright then well I got misguided I'm so
old what's really interesting is I was
in that paradox universe for both
forever and not at all to me like it
might as well have not been noticeable
it was like an endless loop Wow wait so
I'm I'm young again when I go out
ah okay so all right let me let me wrap
my head around all this because this is
getting a little complicated here so we
were in that universe I was in like the
analogy a loop with that Anani we were
the ant but the guy the interdimensional
traveler was bounding around wherever he
goes and every time he bound in he
disrupted things and caused things to
reset and that he contained this diner
in that loop so that every time we'd go
around it everything would be exactly
the same and yet totally different as he
hid it and went by so we as the person
trapped in there was both everyone at
once going through it for all that time
forever
that we were in there and at the same
time we were the one that leaves because
it was all occurring at the same time
because the way time was looped so it
was one unit and one moment but it took
a lifetime get what I'm saying see the
way out whatever I'm not gonna be I'm
not probably not being explaining it
correctly but either way that was
interesting that was really interesting
and I like the thought experiment of it
like other interdimensional travelers
accidentally [ __ ] up your entire
existence just going beeps my bad and
then like what do you take from that you
don't remember any of it because it
never occurred but you were changing it
as it goes by you are the one that
changed it and you were the one
experiencing the changes all once
because not only you made the change in
one moment but that one moment spread
across the entirety of all the changes
do you know what that like do you do you
understand what I'm saying here you are
not one you are all and then all is just
one okay anyway I'm done anyway so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this I certainly did
this is really cool I like it definitely
a departure from the other like the one
thing this guy makes is really David
Mills
is really varied subjects and really
varied types of games and I can
definitely appreciate that so let me
know what you thought of this down in
the comments below if you got some other
opinions about it and you think I'm
wrong I'm definitely willing to hear it
put it down the comments as well thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]